so if we're considering something that
looks very similar to our paper
prototype why would we make one for this
it's important to go back to the idea of
circles of feedback our paper prototype
was a thing that we could show to people
who are nearby and who we knew the
medium fidelity prototype will be
something we can show to subject matter
experts and users as well by expanding
our net we can gather more information
on the app's experience from each of
these vital perspectives with an
interactive prototype we can ask users
to complete task and see how they go
about doing it we can ask them to
explore the app looking for a certain
functionality most importantly we can
get out of their way and see their raw
reaction to the app